>> HEY, YOU! COME HERE!
NOT
THATCLOSE.
THAT'S BETTER.
SO YOU THINK YOU'RE ABOUT TO SEE
A TYPICAL EPISODE
OF "TOP MODEL," DON'T YOU?
YOU KNOW, ME AND J's
SITTING BEHIND THAT DESK,
AND ALL THE GIRLS WALK IN
AND TRY TO IMPRESS US.
WE ALL KNOW THATGIRL...
(squeals) I'M 19 YEARS OLD,
AND MY FAVORITE DESIGNER
IS HELLO KITTY.
I WOULD DO ANYTHING, ANYTHING,
ANYTHING TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL...
EXCEPT CUT MY HAIR.
WHOO!
I CAN SMIZE, LIKE, WITH MY EYES.
I'M DOING IT.
AND THIS ONE...
I WANT THIS.
MY NAME IS ANGORA NYLANDRA
TAFATIA MICHAELS.
I'M NOT HERE TO MAKE FRIENDS.
WHAT DO I HAVE
THAT THE OTHER GIRLS DON'T HAVE?
HELLO?
AND LET'S NOT FORGET...
(whispers) THAT ONE...
LOOK, LET ME START OFF BY SAYING
I DON'T WANT TO BE HERE.
I AMMY ART.
(growling)
WHAT?
I DON'T KNOW THE FIRST THING
ABOUT POSING.
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M DOING.
I HAVE NO IDEA,
I'M NOT A COOKIE CUTTER.
I CUT THE COOKIES,
AND I'LL CUT YOU.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> FORGET THAT.
I'M THROWING CASTING WEEK
OUT THE WINDOW.
(whoosh, glass shatters)
>> THE 14 GIRLS OF CYCLE 16
ARE MOVING
INTO THE "TOP MODEL" HOUSE
IN THE NEXT TEN MINUTES.
>> (cheering)
>> AND BY THE END OF TONIGHT,
THEY'RE GONNA BE FACING
ME, NIGEL, AND ANDRÉ
IN THE JUDGING ROOM,
AND ONE OF THEM
WILL BE SENT HOME.
SO WHO STAYS
IN THIS COMPETITION?
BUT FIRST,
I'M GONNA TAKE A CUE
FROM TWITTER KING
AND ULTIMATE PRANKSTER HIMSELF--
ASHTON KUTCHER.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> IN A FEW MINUTES,
WE'RE GONNA DROP THE BOMB
ON 14 OF THESE GIRLS.
THEY'RE GONNA THINK
THEY'RE OUT OF THE COMPETITION,
BUT REALLY, THEY'RE IN.
>> I'M KINDA IN SHOCK RIGHT NOW.
>> SO WHY ARE WE DOING THIS?
WELL, WE FELT IT WAS TIME
TO GET REAL BECAUSE
IN THE REAL MODELING INDUSTRY,
THE FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS
IS REJECTION.
>> HER LOOK IS A LITTLE BIT
TWO SEASONS AGO.
>> AND YOU'VE GOT TO
GO OUT THERE AND FACE REJECTION
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> HAD TO LET HER GO.
>> NOT GOOD...
AT ALL.
>> AND DON'T THINK THAT GIRLS
LIKE GISELE AND CHANEL AND KATE
DIDN'T DEAL WITH IT.
AND ME?
I WAS REJECTED BY SIX AGENCIES
BEFORE I GOT SIGNED.
AND TO THIS DAY,
I STILL HAVE TO DEAL
WITH PEOPLE SAYING "NO."
NO. NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
HELL, NO! I DON'T THINK SO.
>> COME ON!
>> IF YOU WANT
ITALIAN "VOGUE," IMG,
AND A CONTRACT WITH COVERGIRL,
THEN YOU BETTER HAVE SKIN
TOUGHER THAN
A LEATHER PRADA BAG.
SO... WHAT BETTER WAY
TO TOUGHEN UP OUR GIRLS
THAN TO MAKE THEMTHINK
THEY'RE GOING HOME?
LIKE BRITTANI--SHE THINKS
SHE'S BEING SENT PACKING,
BUT HER TEARS AREN'T
GONNA COME CLOSE
TO THE BREAKDOWN
SHE HAS THIS SEASON.
>> I'M HAVING A PANIC ATTACK.
I CAN'T REALLY... (gasps) TALK.
>> AND THERE'S JACLYN.
THIS SWEET SOUTHERN GIRL
THINKS SHE'S A REJECT.
BUT THIS CYCLE,
SHE'S REALLY GONNA HAVE TO DEAL
WITH HER BIGGEST CRITIC--
HERSELF.
>> YOU CAN'T MODEL
BECAUSE YOU HAVE A BABY FACE!
GROW UP!
>> AND THEN THERE'S ALEXANDRIA.
WHEN SHE THOUGHT SHE WAS CUT,
SHE WAS AS TOUGH AS NAILS.
>> DOESN'T MEAN I'M GONNA STOP.
>> BUT THIS SEASON,
THIS GIRL'S TOUGH SKIN IS GONNA
RUB A LOT OF THE GIRLS RAW.
>> CROSS IT OVER AND STEP AGAIN.
NOW DO IT ONE MORE TIME.
>> WE'RE JUST LIKE, "SHUT UP.
NO ONE WANTS TO HEAR ANYTHING
THAT YOU HAVE TO SAY ANYMORE."
>> WANNA SEE WHAT
MADE THESE GIRLS SO UPSET?
>> I REALLY, REALLY WANTED THIS
REALLY BAD.
>> WELL, GET READY
FOR THE BIGGEST SWERVE
"TOP MODEL" HAS EVER TAKEN.
AND IT STARTS RIGHT NOW.
(man speaking indistinctly
over P.A.)
>> IT ALL STARTED WHEN
THE GIRLS WERE FLOWN TO L.A.
FOR WHAT THEY THINK IS
A REGULAR CASTING WEEK.
(singsongy) BUT WE KNOW
IT'S NOT!
(normal voice) WE STARTED
IMMEDIATELY
ON THE AIRPORT RUNWAY.
AND LIKE ANY OTHER
CASTING WEEK,
THE J's HAD TO EVALUATE
THEIR WALK.
>> LET'S GO.
>> THERE'S MONIQUE.
THERE WAS A BIG CONCERN
ABOUT MONIQUE BEING
WAY TOO SEXY.
AND I KNOW THE FASHION INDUSTRY
IS GONNA THINK
I HAVE LOST MY MIND,
BUT I SWEAR I SEE
SOME SHALOM HARLOW IN HER--
A SUPERMODEL FROMMY DAY.
>> I'M USED TO BEING
THE CENTER OF ATTENTION
WITHOUT EVEN HAVING TO OP--
REALLY OPEN MY MOUTH.
>> MIGHT BE BRINGING
THE WRONG CROWD TO THE TABLE.
>> OR THE RIGHTCROWD,
IF YOU ASK ME.
GO ON, BABY.
>> THAT'S KASIA,
A PLUS-SIZE MODEL.
BUT WHAT I PREFER TO CALL
FIERCELY REAL.
AND SHE'S PROVEN
SHE'S HIGH FASHION
BECAUSE SHE'S ALREADY BEEN
IN "V MAGAZINE."
SO MISS KASIA BETTER BRING IT.
>> DEFINITELY THINK THERE'S
A PLACE FOR FULL-FIGURED MODELS
IN HIGH FASHION.
I CAN BE IN A LINEUP
OF STRAIGHT-SIZED GIRLS
AND I CAN STAND OUT
AND I CAN BE THE ONE
THAT THE CLIENT'S GONNA WANT.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> AND THIS IS SARA.
ILOVE THAT ANDROGYNOUS LOOK.
BUT CHECK OUT
THAT RATTAIL THING HANGING OFF
THE BACK OF HER HEAD.
I CANNOT WAIT
TO CUT THAT THING OFF
AT MAKEOVERS...
IF SHE MAKES IT THAT FAR.
>> I DEFINITELY THINK
I'M QUIRKY, A BIT ECCENTRIC,
AND IT COMES OUT... (laughs)
IN THE WAY I MOVE.
I HAVE SO MUCH TO LEARN
ABOUT MODELING.
IT IS RIDICULOUS.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> OKAY, SO THE GIRLS THINK
THAT EVERYTHING IS LIKE USUAL.
THEY WALKED, THEY TOOK A PHOTO,
AND I MET THEM.
>> (screaming)
>> HEY, EVERYBODY!
BUT THAT'S WHERE
EVERYTHING CHANGED.
(tires screech)
>> WHILE THE GIRLS RUN OFF
TO MINGLE
ANDTHOUGHT THAT THEY WERE
KICKING OFF CASTING WEEK,
THEY DIDN'T KNOW THAT
WE WERE ALREADY MAKING
OUR FINAL CHOICES.
>> SEE THE CAST HERE.
>> PUT HER ON THE BOARD!
>> YAY! (laughs)
>> REALLY DO.
>> AND I CHOSE
MY FINAL 14 GIRLS--
FRECKLE-FACED DOMINIQUE,
FIERCELY REAL KASIA,
PETITE ONDREI,
SPICY BLONDE ALEXANDRIA,
SEXY MAMA MONIQUE,
ELEGANT NICOLE,
QUIRKY SARA,
HIPPIE HANNAH,
GOLDEN-HAIRED MOLLY,
BABY-FACED JACLYN,
BRITTANI FROM THE BLOCK,
REGAL DALYA,
EDGY MIKAELA,
AND SASSY ANGELIA.
>> HELLO!
>> (cheering)
>> MORNING!
LOOK, WE GOT SOME STUFF FOR YOU.
>> WE THINK WE'RE JUST, LIKE,
AT THIS INNOCENT LITTLE
RECEPTION,
AND THEN MR. AND MISS J
WALK OUT,
AND THEY HAVE SOME ENVELOPES
IN THEIR HANDS.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
>> YOU GUYS KNOW
THIS CASTING PROCESS
INSIDE AND OUT,
SO YOU'RE PROBABLY WONDERING,
"OOH, WHEN IS PANEL
GONNA HAPPEN?" RIGHT?
>> YEAH!
>> WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT?
SOME TOUGH DECISIONS
HAVE ALREADY BEEN MADE...
>> OOH!
>> AND SOME OF YOU
AREN'T GOING TO PANEL.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> IN SOME OF THESE ENVELOPES,
THERE WILL BE A PHOTO.
BUT FOR THOSE
WHO DO NOT HAVE A PHOTO,
YOU WILL BE GOING HOME.
>> (gasps)
>> RIGHT NOW.
>> OH!
>> THEY SHOULD JUST
OPEN THEM RIGHT NOW.
>> YEAH!
>> OPEN THEM.
>> GO AHEAD, OPEN 'EM.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> YES!
>> (screaming)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> SO I KNOW THERE ARE
A LOT OF EMOTIONS GOING ON
RIGHT NOW,
AND THIS A TOUGH MOMENT.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
IN THE WORLD OF MODELING,
THERE'S REJECTION,
THERE ARE DIFFICULT TIMES.
AND FOR THOSE
WHO DON'T HAVE A PHOTO,
I'M SORRY THAT YOU FEEL UPSET
RIGHT NOW.
BUT FOR THOSE GIRLS
WHO DO HAVE A PHOTO,
COME WITH US.
>> GIRLS WITH PHOTOS.
>> I'M REALLY DISAPPOINTED.
IT'S HARD GOING BACK
TO A LIFE THAT
YOU REALLY DIDN'T HAVE
TOO MUCH ANYWAY. (sniffles)
I'M NOT IN SCHOOL ANYMORE.
I DON'T HAVE A JOB.
(sniffles)
YOU KNOW, THIS IS MY LIFE NOW,
AND THIS--
NOW I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING.
>> WE GOT THIS FAR
OUT OF THOUSANDS OF GIRLS.
WE'RE TOTALLY OKAY.
>> YEAH.
I FELT PRETTY CONFIDENT.
UM... (chuckles)
I HATE CRYING.
(exhales deeply)
>> YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL.
>> SO ARE YOU.
>> YOU REALLY ARE.
YOU DON'T NEED TO CRY.
>> IT'S JUST A HUGE LETDOWN.
JUST COMPLETELY LET DOWN.
I DON'T WANT TO GO HOME.
>> OKAY, SO, YOU GUYS,
I'M TAKING YOU
ONTO THE ELEVATORS.
WE'RE GONNA HEAD UP.
WE'RE GONNA GRAB YOUR BAGS
AND WE'LL HEAD UP.
(indistinct conversations)
>> WE GO INTO
THIS BASEMENT-LOOKING ROOM,
AND OUR LUGGAGE IS JUST, LIKE,
PLONK.
WE'RE NOTHING TO ANYBODY
ANYMORE.
>> JUST COME ON IN
AND FIND YOUR BAG, GUYS,
AND THEN WE'LL TAKE YOU
DOWN TO THE BUS.
>> MINE'S UNDER...
(speaks indistinctly)
>> TYRA ALWAYS FEELS
REALLY BAD ABOUT THIS,
AND SHE ALWAYS LIKES
TO GET A CHANCE
TO SAY GOOD-BYE TO YOU
BEFORE YOU GUYS TAKE OFF
AND GO HOME, SO SHE'LL BE OVER
TO SAY GOOD-BYE.
>> I DON'T WANT TO SEE TYRA.
I MEAN, LIKE,
YEAH, I WANNA SEE TYRA, BUT GOD,
THIS IS SO EMBARRASSING.
>> SO SAD.
>> HI, LADIES.
>> HI.
>> I'M SO SORRY.
>> IT'S OKAY.
>> BUT YOU GUYS
CAN'T GIVE UP, RIGHT?
>> NO.
>> RIGHT. THIS IS, LIKE,
YOU GUYS GOT REALLY FAR.
>> THE TEARS KEEP COMING,
AND YOU'RE TRYING
TO HOLD THEM BACK
AND YOU CAN'T HOLD THEM BACK
ANYMORE BECAUSE SHE'S COMING
TO SAY GOOD-BYE. THIS IS IT.
>> I HAVE GOTTEN, LIKE,
SO TURNED DOWN,
DOORS SLAMMED IN MY FACE.
THE ROAD TO SUCCESS
AND TO THE TOP
IS NOT A STRAIGHT LINE.
IT'S A ZIGZAG LINE.
SO UNFORTUNATELY,
YOU GUYS HAVE TO GO HOME NOW,
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO FAR...
>> OH!
>> WHAT?
>> BECAUSE YOU'RE HOME!
>> (screaming)
>> YOU GUYS ARE THE 14!
>> WHOO!
>> (crying) I LITERALLY FELL.
I COLLAPSED.
I COULDN'T EVEN BREATHE.
SHE HAD TO LITERALLY
COME OVER AND PICK ME UP,
'CAUSE I WAS ON THE FLOOR.
I COULDN'T MOVE.
>> (screaming)
>> OH, MY GOD.
THEY TRICKED US.
I SEE MY PICTURE OVER THERE
AND ALL
THE OTHER GIRLS' PICTURES,
AND I'M 1 OF THOSE 14 GIRLS.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE IT.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> (screams)
I'M, LIKE, FREAKING OUT STILL.
I WANT TO CRY, BUT I'M SO HAPPY,
AND, LIKE, AAH!
>> (speaking indistinctly)
>> I AM READY TO WORKIT!
I AM AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
RECOGNIZE MY FACE
AND GET USED TO IT. (laughs)
>> I KNOW YOU GUYS
THOUGHT IT WAS WEIRD
THAT THE FIERCEST 14
WAS GOING HOME, RIGHT?
>> YEAH!
>> YOU'RE LIKE, "WAIT.
WE'RE ALL BEST.
WHY ARE WE GOING HOME?"
BECAUSE YOU WEREN'T GOING HOME.
>> (screaming)
>> THIS IS YOUR HOUSE.
TOTALLY GORGEOUS. IT'S CYCLE 16.
SO ALL THE PICTURES OF ME
IN THE HOUSE
ARE WHEN I WAS 16 YEARS OLD.
SO I'M GONNA GET OUT OF HERE
BEFORE YOU GUYS BEAT ME UP.
GOOD-BYE! BYE!
>> NOW THAT WE'RE HERE,
I'M, LIKE, SUPER EXCITED.
I WANNA SEE MY ROOM NOW.
I CAN'T WAIT. I CAN'T WAIT.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> (laughs)
>> YEAH?
>> OBVIOUSLY.
>> I DO LIVE IN A TRAILER PARK,
AND SO COMING FROM A TRAILER
TO A PENTHOUSE
IN DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES,
IT'S ABSOLUTELY AMAZING.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT RIGHT NOW.
>> I HAVE A HOUSE MEETING,
LADIES.
CAN I HAVE EVERYBODY
INSIDE THE LIVING ROOM, PLEASE?
IF YOU HAVE THE ELEPHANT
IN YOUR HAND, THEN YOU CAN TALK.
>> WE HAVE A SILLIER ELEPHANT.
SO WHAT'S HAPPENING?
NO.
>> BEING THROWN INTO A SITUATION
WHERE THERE ARE
13 OTHER GIRLS IN THE HOUSE
IS, UH...
CRAZY.
>> MIKAELA.
>> THIS IS WHAT I WANT
TO TELL Y'ALL.
>> PEOPLE LIKE DOMINIQUE ARE
GOING AROUND THE HOUSE
LIKE THEY ALREADY OWN THE PLACE.
>> GIRLS.
COME ON. LET'S FIGURE THIS OUT.
>> ALEXANDRIA HAS A...
VERY BIG MOUTH.
>> SOMETHING'S WRONG.
>> SHE DEFINITELY THINKS
SHE'S THE...
>> IT'S DONE! SHH!
>> I'M OBSESSED WITH JACLYN.
>> HOW IS ALL OF OUR STUFF
GONNA FIT IN THAT CLOSET?
>> SHE'S SO CUTE.
I JUST LOVE HER.
>> I'M REALLY, REALLY GOOD
AT HIGH FIVES.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TRY? YEAH!
>> SARA HAS
A REALLY INTERESTING LOOK,
BUT SARA DOES NOT KNOW
THAT SHE HAS A LOOK
WORTHY OF BEING HERE.
>> WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
>> I'M NOT GONNA LET, YOU KNOW,
THIS CRAZY STUFF
THAT EVERYONE ELSE IS DOING,
YOU KNOW, GET IN THE WAY
OF WHAT IS THE GOAL,
AND THE GOAL IS TO WIN.
>> RAISE YOUR HAND--HAVE
EVERYBODY CLAIMED A BED YET?
>> YEAH.
>> SOMEBODY'S ABOUT
TO GET ELIMINATED,
BECAUSE I AIN'T GOT A BED.
>> ME NEITHER.
>> YOU AIN'T GOT A BED NEITHER?
OH, SO TWO OF US ARE GOING.
>> NO.
>> WE AIN'T GOT NO BEDS.
LIKE, WHERE THE HELL
WE GON' SLEEP?
I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT TO EXPECT NO MO'.
LIKE WE DONE HAD
TOO MANY SURPRISES,
AND I'M JUST TOO NERVOUS
TO EVEN FIGURE OUT WHAT
THE HELL'S GONNA HAPPEN NEXT.
>> THERE'S ONLY 12 BEDS.
>> THERE'S 14 GIRLS.
>> 14 GIRLS.
>> TWO PEOPLE ABOUT TO GO HOME.
>> I KNOW.
>> YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE GONNA PULL
AFTER WHAT THEY PULLED WITH US,
TELLING US WE DIDN'T MAKE IT.
YOU JUST NEVER KNOW.
YOU CONSTANTLY HAVE TO
BE ON YOUR TOES.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> (screaming)
>> "LET'S GET THE BALL ROLLING.
SHALL WE?"
(singsongy) "LOVE, TYRA."
>> I THINK IT SOUNDS GRACEFUL.
>> WE'LL BE MODELING
BOWLING SHOES.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE HECK
THIS TYRA MAIL MEANS.
IT COULD BE
WE'RE GOING TO A BALL,
WE'RE GOING TO A BOWLING ALLEY.
THAT--THOSE ARE THE TWO THINGS
I'M--I'M THINKING
THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> HI.
>> THAT'S ERIN.
>> WE SHOW UP
TO THIS REALLY GORGEOUS HOUSE
IN MALIBU.
UM, THE FIRST THING WE SEE IS
BEAUTIFUL ERIN WASSON.
>> NOW I ALREADY HEARD
SOME OF YOU GUYS, WHEN YOU WERE
WALKING OUT OF THE BUS,
YOU GUYS KNOW THAT THIS IS
ERIN WASSON RIGHT HERE.
>> HOW COULD YOU NOT KNOW?
>> YEAH. AND YOU SHOULD KNOW
WHO SHE IS.
>> YES.
>> SHE HAS WALKED
FOR THE TOP DESIGNERS.
SHE'S BEEN SHOT
BY THE BEST PHOTOGRAPHERS
ALL OVER THE WORLD,
AND NOT THAT SHE'S BUSY ENOUGH,
SHE'S ALSO A STYLIST
AND JEWELRY DESIGNER.
>> YES.
>> WE ARE STANDING HERE
IN MALIBU TODAY,
WHICH IS GONNA BE THE BACKDROP
FOR YOUR FIRST RUNWAY SHOW.
(bell dings)
>> (screaming)
>> AND FOR TODAY'S FASHION SHOW,
YOU GUYS ARE ALL
GOING TO BE WEARING LOOKS
FROM A DEAR FRIEND OF MINE--
T BY ALEXANDER WANG.
>> (screaming)
>> YES?
I KNOW YOU GUYS LOVE
SOME A. WANG--
AND ACTUALLY, SOME PIECES
FROM MY OWN JEWELRY COLLECTION
LOW LUV.
>> AND EVERYBODY STARTS
RIGHT NOW.
NOW THERE IS SOMETHING
THAT YOU GUYS SHOULD KNOW
ABOUT YOUR RUNWAY SHOW.
YOU GUYS ARE GONNA BE WALKING
ON A 12-INCH-WIDE RUNWAY
OVER WATER...
>> OH!
>> WHOO!
>> IN ONE
OF THESE PLASTIC BUBBLES.
>> (cheering)
>> WHAT IF THEY CAN'T IT OPEN
AND I'M STUCK IN THAT BUBBLE
FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE?
LIKE, THAT WENT THROUGH MY HEAD
A MILLION TIMES.
>> NOW ANOTHER VERY REAL ASPECT
OF THE MODELING WORLD TODAY--
WHEN YOU GO BACKSTAGE
AT ANY FASHION SHOW,
YOU'RE GONNA SEE
A PHOTO SHOOT HAPPENING.
SO FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN "TOP MODEL" HISTORY,
WE'RE GONNA DO
THE EXACT SAME THING.
YOU'RE GONNA DO A PHOTO SHOOT
FIRST BACKSTAGE
BEFORE YOU EVEN GO OUT.
NOW TODAY'S PHOTOGRAPHER IS
ONE OF THE NICEST...
>> OH.
>> TALENTED TOP PHOTOGRAPHERS.
HE HAS SHOT
COUNTLESS SUPERMODELS,
INCLUDING TYRA HERSELF.
SO YOU'RE
IN THE VERY CAPABLE HANDS
OR MR. RUSSELL JAMES.
>> (screaming)
>> THEY ALL KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
>> I HOPE YOU CAN KEEP
THAT ENERGY,
AND I HOPE YOU CAN FIND
THAT ENERGY...
>> YES!
>> WHEN WE DO
OUR BACKSTAGE SHOOT.
>> HERE'S ERIN WASSON.
AND THEN RUSSELL JAMES COMES UP.
NOT TO MENTION THEY'RE LIKE,
"OH, AND YOU'RE GONNA BE WEARING
ALEXANDER WANG'S CLOTHING."
THIS CAN'T BE REAL RIGHT NOW.
IT'S SO INCREDIBLY AWESOME.
>> SO LET'S GET YOU GUYS--
COME WITH US.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE YOU
TO HAIR AND MAKEUP.
>> (screaming)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WHAT ARE YOU DOING WITH HER?
>> BENDING A LITTLE BIT
ON THE ENDS
SO IT GIVES IT THE BEACHY LOOK.
>> COOL. I KNOW. LOOK--
I LOVED THAT TEXTURE
AS SOON AS I SAW IT.
IT LOOKS NICE.
IN THIS MODERN MARKET,
THE BACKSTAGE AREA
HAS BECOME AS IMPORTANT
IF NOT MORE IMPORTANT
THAN WHAT I WOULD CALL
THE FRONT STAGE.
IN MY OWN BOOK THAT IS TITLED
"RUSSELL JAMES,"
I FEATURE A SECTION THAT IS
ENTIRELY ABOUT BACKSTAGE,
AND IT TAKES MODELS
WITH A VERY SPECIAL TALENT
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON.
LOOK MORE.
GORGEOUS.
NO, TRUST ME.
DEFINITELY GREAT THERAPY.
>> THIS WHOLE EXPERIENCE IS
JUST INCREDIBLE RIGHT NOW.
RUSSELL JAMES SHOOTS
VICTORIA'S SECRET MODELS
LIKE TYRA AND GISELE
AND ADRIANA.
IT WAS JUST LIKE,
I GET TO WORK WITH THIS MAN?
>> GORGEOUS.
BEAUTIFUL.
>> THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT
YOUR FACE THAT HAS AN INTENSITY.
WOULDN'T YOU AGREE? JUST LIKE...
>> ABSOLUTELY. ABSOLUTELY.
GOOD.
BEAUTIFUL.
>> YOU LOVE TO PUSH
YOUR UPPER LIP OUT.
>> (laughs)
>> SEE? NOW HE'S SHOOTING YOU
AND YOU'RE NOT PUSHING IT OUT.
IT LOOKS BETTER.
>> I HAVE NATURAL SWAG.
YOU EITHER HAVE IT OR YOU DON'T.
I REALLY DON'T CARE
WHAT ANYBODY HAS TO SAY
BECAUSE I'M ME.
UM, IF THEY DON'T LIKE IT,
WELL, YOU DON'T HAVE TO LIKE ME.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> I NOW KNIGHT YOU, MY CHILD.
>> (chuckles)
>> THERE'S LIGHT IN THE BACK.
DON'T LOOK.
EXACTLY. THAT'S GREAT.
RIGHT THERE. BEAUTIFUL.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> I DEFINITELY HAVE A LEG UP
ON MOST OF THE GIRLS
JUST WITH ALL THE EXPERIENCE
I HAVE, BUT, LIKE,
I'M GONNA WORK SO MUCH HARDER
THAN ANYBODY ELSE
BECAUSE I THINK I HAVE TO
AS A PLUS-SIZE MODEL.
>> GOOD LIGHT.
BEAUTIFUL.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> GORGEOUS. JUST FEEL THAT EYE.
I JUST WANNA GET
INTO THE EYE THERE.
>> EVERYONE IS HERE
FOR A REASON, AND I'M HERE
BECAUSE OF MY BABY FACE.
I JUST NEED SOME HELP
FROM, YOU KNOW, THE J's
AND EVERYONE TO SHOW ME
HOW TO WORK MY ANGLES,
AND HOPEFULLY
A GOOD PICTURE COMES OUT.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> THANK YOU.
GOOD.
NOW JUST LOOK TO ME HERE,
SWEETIE.
LOOK AT ME HERE. BEAUTIFUL.
>> IT'S NOT
ANY OTHER PHOTO SHOOT.
THIS IS, LIKE, YOUR PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU'RE ACTUALLY
GETTING YOUR HAIR, MAKEUP,
AND WARDROBE DONE,
AND I'M JUST LIKE, OKAY,
DOMINIQUE, WE GOTTA GO HARD,
LIKE, AS ALWAYS,
GO HARD OR GO HOME.
>> NICE.
BEAUTIFUL.
>> (speaks indistinctly)
I'M A BIG DORK.
I WAS A BAND MAJOR. BAND GEEK.
I'VE PLAYED SPORTS A LOT.
I HATE LOSING. HATE IT.
SO I'M DEFINITELY COMPETITIVE.
I-I ALWAYS WANT TO WIN.
>> GOOD. GORGEOUS. VERY NICE.
YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL. GOOD.
JUST DO WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
BEAUTIFUL.
NICE.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> JUST BE COOL WITH IT.
YEAH.
I WANT TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
BECAUSE IT'S A DREAM OF MINE,
JUST THE WHOLE INDUSTRY--
THE HIGH FASHION,
THE TRAVELING.
I GREW UP IN THE MILITARY,
AND I LOVE TRAVELING.
IT'S HELPED ME BECOME
A BETTER PERSON.
>> NICE. BEAUTIFUL.
>> REALLY THINK ABOUT
THE RUNWAY SHOW
YOU'RE ABOUT TO DO RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE WE'RE LOOKING
FOR ELEGANT, CHIC WALKS.
I MEAN, YOU GUYS ARE SELLING
THE WHOLE GARMENT
AND THE JEWELRY.
>> I THINK THIS FASHION SHOW IS
GONNA BE REALLY EXCITING.
AND FOR ME, I'M NOT THINKING
ABOUT THE PICTURES ANYMORE.
I'M THINKING ABOUT MY WALK,
'CAUSE WALKING IN A BUBBLE--
KINDA NERVE-RACKING.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> FIERCE, CONFIDENT,
FABULOUS WALKS.
LONG STRIDES.
>> AND WHAT YOU GUYS
DON'T REALIZE IS I'M ACTUALLY
GOING TO BE YOUR JUDGE AT PANEL.
SO TODAY I'M GONNA
BE WATCHING YOU GUYS,
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS
TO PRETEND THAT THE BUBBLE IS
INVISIBLE.
>> OKAY. ARE YOU READY?
ARE YOU PSYCHED?
>> (cheering)
>> OKAY.
A BUNCH OF BUSTED-UP GIRLS.
>> (laughs)
>> COME ON, CHILD.
♪♪♪♪♪
(whirring)
>> ALEXANDRIA, HIT IT.
♪ THIS IS THE ULTIMATE ♪
>> NOT ONLY ARE WE
ON A 12-INCH BAR,
WE'RE OVER WATER.
AND THEN THEY'RE LIKE, "OH,
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA PUT YOU
IN THIS BIG-ASS PLASTIC BALL."
I'M LIKE, I'M GONNA BE
THE ONE THAT FALLS
BECAUSE I'M THAT CLUMSY.
(chuckles)
♪ THIS IS THE ULTIMATE ♪
♪ GO FOR IT ♪
♪ GO, GO, GO ♪
>> ONDREI, GO.
♪ THIS IS THE ULTIMATE ♪
>> I HAVEN'T HAD MUCH EXPERIENCE
WITH RUNWAY,
SO MY MIND IS THINKING
ABOUT THAT 12-INCH RUNWAY,
AND I'M SCARED TO DEATH.
♪ THIS IS THE ULTIMATE ♪
(audience gasps)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WHOO!
(audience gasps)
>> OH!
DID I SERIOUSLY JUST FALL
IN THIS WATER?
OH, CRAP.
>> BE FABULOUS!
>> AND THE ONLY THING
I COULD THINK ABOUT WAS
GETTING BACK UP AGAIN.
I'M LIKE, OKAY, WHATEVER.
I'M IN THE WATER.
I GOTTA PICK MYSELF UP AGAIN.
I GOTTA GET BACK ON DRY LAND,
WHICH I SHOULD BE ON
IN THE FIRST PLACE. (laughs)
>> (cheering)
>> POWERFUL, FAST WALK.
OWN IT. ALL RIGHT, GO.
♪♪♪♪♪
♪ GO ♪
>> OH, IT'S CLUMSY.
>> NAIL IT.
MISS J.'s WATCHING.
GO.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WHEN DID HANDS ON THE HIPS
BECOME IN FASHION?
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I'M JUST THINKING,
YOU KNOW WHAT? THERE'S MUSIC.
I'M GONNA ROCK THE BEAT.
I'M JUST GONNA WORK IT,
AND I LIKE TO THINK THAT I DID.
>> LOOK, SHE IS NAILINGTHIS.
>> (laughs)
>> WHOO!
>> THAT WAS REALLY GOOD.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> ANGELIA, LET'S GO.
>> GIVE ME ANOTHER RUNWAY
WITHOUT A BUBBLE,
AND I'LL SHOW YOU WHAT I HAVE,
BUT I MEAN, THAT'S
A ONE-IN-A-LIFETIME EXPERIENCE,
THOUGH.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I DON'T KNOW
HOW THE BUBBLE MOVES,
BUT IT'S JUST, LIKE,
IT'S NOT WORKING PROPERLY.
I THINK I HAD GOTTEN, LIKE,
A DEFECTIVE BUBBLE OR SOMETHING.
>> OH, GOD.
>> GIRL DOWN.
(whimsical music playing)
>> (laughs)
(applause)
>> I'M LIKE, YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE ABOUT TO END THIS BITCH
WITH A BANG,
SO I WAS LIKE, VOILÀ,
LIKE, I'M OUT THIS BITCH.
>> I KNOW MISS J. IS ITCHING
TO DIG INTO THESE WALKS.
MISS J., WHEN DID TWO HANDS
ON THE HIPS BECOME VOGUE
WHEN YOU'RE WALKING
DOWN THE RUNWAY?
>> YOU ALL WALKED AS THOUGH YOU
WERE ON AN OVERDOSE OF VIAGRA.
IT WAS JUST STIFF--
>> EXCEPT FOR ONE
WHO CAME OUT OF THE GATE--
>> BUT MISS BRITTANI CAME OUT
OF--LIKE A PONY OUT OF THE GATE.
>> CAME OUT, MADE THAT TURN
LIKE NOBODY'S BUSINESS.
IT WAS AMAZING.
>> BRAVO TO YOU, SWEETIE.
>> YES.
>> BRAVO.
>> OVERALL, I'M JUST--
I'M IMPRESSED, 'CAUSE I SAID
BEFORE THIS WHOLE CHALLENGE,
I DON'T EVEN THINK
I COULD PULL THAT OFF.
>> WELL, I REALLY LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING THE FINAL PICKS
OF RUSSELL'S AMAZING PHOTOGRAPHY
'CAUSE THE SHOTS WERE GREAT.
>> AND, LADIES,
A LITTLE SURPRISE, YOU GUYS.
I WANNA GIFT YOU
ONE OF MY PIECES OF JEWELRY.
>> (screaming)
>> BRAVO FOR
YOUR FIRST FASHION SHOW
FOR "TOP MODEL" CYCLE 16.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WHAT IS THAT?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> (screaming)
>> "TOMORROW YOU WILL HAVE
YOUR FIRST MEETING
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY 13 WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPE OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
>> ALL RIGHT!
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> SOMEBODY IS GOING HOME.
TODAY I WENT INSIDE
OF THIS BIG-ASS BUBBLE
LOOKING LIKE A... GERBIL,
AND I'M JUST HOPING
THAT PANEL IS GONNA, LIKE,
SEE THAT I HAVE SOMETHING IN ME
AND THAT THEY WILL JUST
KINDA, LIKE, LET THAT GO.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU HAVE.
YOU H--ALREADY HAVE IT.
I KNOW THIS IS BRAND-NEW
FOR YOU.
YOU WANNA WIN?
>> I DO.
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> ALEXANDRIA--
LIKE, SHE'S ALWAYS, LIKE,
KINDA TREATING JACLYN
LIKE A LITTLE 4-YEAR-OLD.
>> WATCH MY FEET.
LAST STEP.
NOW DO ONE MORE TIME.
ONE MORE TIME.
>> HOW CAN YOU NOT KNOW
THAT THIS IS
WHAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO KNOW?
YOU'RE--THIS--
YOU'RE SUPPOSED DO
YOUR HOMEWORK, GIRL.
I'VE LITERALLY SPENT
THIS PAST YEAR MODELING.
I DID L.A. FASHION WEEK.
I DID NEW YORK FASHION WEEK.
SO WITH ELIMINATION WEEK
COMING UP, I FEEL SECURE.
YOU HAVE IT IN HERE.
KNOCK IT OFF.
WHAT I'M SAYING IS FROM NOW ON--
>> I FEEL LIKE YOU'RE MY MOTHER.
>> (laughs)
>> I MIGHT NOT HAVE
AS MUCH EXPERIENCE
AS SOME OF THE OTHER GIRLS,
BUT I REALLY, REALLY HOPE
THAT THE JUDGES SEE IN ME
THAT I DO HAVE POTENTIAL
TO LEARN AND TO GROW
IN THE MODELING INDUSTRY.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> OHH!
I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS.
YOU GOT A T-SHIRT WITH ME.
I LOVE IT. THAT'S SO SWEET.
(laughs)
>> IT'S VERY CUTE. VERY CUTE.
>> IT'S REALLY CUTE. (laughs)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> HELLO, LADIES.
>> HI, TYRA.
>> "TOP MODEL" HAS MADE
A LOTOF CHANGES
BECAUSE WE ARE NOW IN THE MIDST
OF BEING HIGH FASHION.
I AM PAYING HOMAGE
TO HIGH FASHION RIGHT NOW
BY SPORTING
THE LOVELY ANDRÉ LEON TALLEY
ON MY BODY.
AND HE FEELS SO GOOD.
>> (laughs)
>> THE FIRST JUDGE IS
NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER...
>> HI, LADIES.
>> THEN WE HAVE
ANDRÉ LEON TALLEY, ONE OF
THEMOST INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE
IN ALL OF THE FASHION INDUSTRY,
AND OUR GUEST JUDGE
WHO YOU GOT TO MEET--
SUPERMODEL AND DESIGNER
ERIN WASSON.
SHE ROCKS IT.
LADIES, YOU KNOW OUR PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS
AND A CONTRACT
WITH ONE OF THE TOP
MODEL MANAGEMENT COMPANIES
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD--
IMG MODELS,
A SPREAD IN ITALIAN "VOGUE"
AND YOU GET A SPREAD
IN "BEAUTY IN VOGUE,"
YOU GET A COVER
OF "BEAUTY IN VOGUE,"
AND YOU GET FEATURED
ON "VOGUE ITALIA'S" WEB SITE,
vogue.it.
ARE WE READY TO START?
>> YES.
>> OKAY. (whispers) LET'S GO.
>> WHOO!
>> SO, LADIES,
THE FASHION INDUSTRY IS
A-CHANGIN'.
WHAT HAPPENS BACKSTAGE IS
JUST AS IMPORTANT TO A DESIGNER
AS WHAT HAPPENS
ON THAT RUNWAY.
AND THAT'S WHY, JUDGES,
THE LADIES'
VERY FIRST PHOTO SHOOT
OF CYCLE 16 WAS ACTUALLY
GETTING READY FOR REAL,
BACKSTAGE,
FOR A FASHION SHOW,
AND THEY WERE SHOT
BY RUSSELL JAMES.
ALEXANDRIA.
ARE YOU READY
FOR YOUR BEST SHOT?
>> I BELIEVE SO.
>> AND HERE IT IS.
>> IT LOOKS AMAZING.
YOUR BONE STRUCTURE IS
PHENOMENAL.
>> ALEXANDRIA, I LOVE HERE THAT
IT'S--IT'S QUITE RAW.
I MEAN, I LOVE THE ESSENCE
OF BLACK AND WHITE
FOR THAT REASON.
THERE'S JUST SOMETHING
REALLY BEAUTIFULLY RAW ABOUT IT.
>> I LOVE YOUR PROFILE.
I THINK THAT, UH,
IT'S VERY DRAMATIC,
AND IT MAKES YOU LOOK GOOD.
I THINK IT'S A MOMENT CAUGHT,
AND IT'S WONDERFUL.
>> I REMEMBER BACKSTAGE
AT FASHION SHOWS,
THERE'D BE SOME MODELS
THAT WERE LIKE...
AND THEIR PICTURES
NEVER RAN IN THE MAGAZINES,
AND THEN THERE WOULD BE THE ONES
LIKE CHRISTY TURLINGTON,
AND SHE'D BE GETTING
HER MAKEUP DONE,
AND SHE'D GO...
LINDA EVANGELISTA, ALL OF 'EM.
SO I WAS LIKE,
OOH, I'M-A DO IT LIKE THAT.
SO I STARTED DOING
MY THING, TOO,
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
IT'S BEHIND THE SCENES,
BUT, HONEY,
ALL THE LIGHTS ARE ON YOU.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> OKAY, UP NEXT IS DALYA.
HELLO.
YOU READY TO SEE YOUR PICTURE?
>> YES, I AM.
>> HERE IT IS.
>> I-I THINK THAT JUST
YOUR NATURAL BEAUTY HERE
COMES OUT.
Y-YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO ANYTHING.
THEY CAUGHT YOU.
>> YEAH, THERE'S WAYS TO PRETEND
LIKE YOU'RE NOT AWARE,
BUT YOU ARE,
SO YOU SLOUCH A LITTLE MORE
OR PUT BOTH ARMS BEHIND YOU
AND KINDA JUST STRETCH A LITTLE,
LIKE, "OH, I'M JUST STRETCHING."
CLICK, CLICK, CLICK.
AND IT LOOKS NATURAL,
BUT IT AIN'T, CHILD.
>> THANKS, GUYS.
>> NICOLE.
DID I FIND YOU ON MY WEB SITE?
>> YOU DID.
>> OH, GIRL, IT KINDA
FREAKS ME OUT SOMETIMES.
OKAY, HERE IT IS.
>> UH, UM,
IT'S--IT'S DRAMATIC.
I'M NOT SURE THAT
IT'S MAKING ME FEEL THAT
THIS IS A BACKSTAGE MOMENT.
WHAT AM I LOOKING FOR?
>> LOOKING AT YOU RIGHT NOW,
YOU LOOK SO YOUNG AND SO FRESH.
LIKE, WHEN I LOOK AT YOUR FILM,
YOU LOOK 15 YEARS OLDER
THAN YOU ARE...
>> WOW.
>> AND THAT'S NOT A GOOD THING.
UP NEXT--MISS RATTAIL SARA.
SHOW THE JUDGES THAT TAIL, SARA.
>> OH.
>> AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> SARA, YOU COULD BE EXUDING
SOMETHING SENSUAL AND SEXY,
BUT I-I DON'T--
YOU HAVEN'T FIGURED OUT
HOW TO GET THERE YET.
>> THIS PICTURE, TO ME,
LOOKS LIKE A 19-YEAR-OLD BOY
WITH MAKEUP ON,
BUT THAT'S WHAT I LIKE ABOUT IT.
THANK YOU, SARA.
>> THANK YOU.
>> NEXT UP IS ONDREI.
>> LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE KIND OF
HOLDING ON,
LIKE, AN ELECTRIC HAIR.
I LIKE IT.
>> I'M NOT CRAZY ABOUT IT.
>> REALLY? I THINK IT'S A GIRL
IN HER FIRST SEASON,
IN PARIS, NERVOUS.
>> YEAH, I SEE THE NERVES.
>> ANGELIA.
>> THERE'S A LITTLE BIT
OF MYSTERY, AND I'M, LIKE,
A GIRL THAT LOVES A LITTLE BIT
OF MYSTERY IN LIFE, BUT WITH IT
BEING YOUR FIRST TIME,
I THINK THAT, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S THE MOMENT TO REALLY,
LIKE, GET OUT OF THE HAIR
AND REALLY LET YOURSELF SHINE
A LITTLE BIT.
>> THIS PICTURE, TO ME,
I DON'T SEE A MODEL.
IT JUST LOOKS LIKE
A REALLY PRETTY GIRL,
LIKE THE GIRL THAT, YOU KNOW,
ALL THE BOYS WANT HER,
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU WANT
TO BE AS A MODEL.
YOU ALMOST KINDA DON'T WANT
THE BOYS TO REALLY WANT YOU.
YOU WANT THE GIRLS
TO WANT WHAT YOU HAVE ON.
>> (chuckles)
>> OKAY? THANK YOU.
HANNAH.
ALL RIGHT,
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> LOOK AT THAT, HANNAH.
I'D SAY THAT'S
AN IMPRESSIVE SHOT
BECAUSE YOU'RE SURROUNDED
BY A WHOLE BUNCH OF OTHER GIRLS,
AND YOU ARE STANDING OUT.
YOU'RE POPPING.
>> THERE'S SOMETHING
YOUNG JENNIFER ANISTON
ABOUT YOU IN THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
BUDDING STAR COMES OUT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT--KASIA.
SO KASIA IS
OUR ONLY FIERCELY REAL
OR PLUS-SIZE MODEL THIS CYCLE.
>> YES.
>> YOU READY TO SEE
YOUR BEST SHOT?
>> YOU GUYS ALL HAVE
SUCH INCREDIBLE PERSONALITIES,
AND YOU AS WELL,
YOU'RE REALLY BUBBLY.
AND IN THAT MOMENT,
I'D LIKE TO SEE YOUR PERSONALITY
COME OUT A BIT MORE.
>> I THINK IT IS SO IMPORTANT
WHEN YOU ARE A BLACK WOMAN
OR WHEN YOU ARE
A FIERCELY REAL PLUS-SIZE WOMAN,
THAT YOU HAVE TO BE BETTER THAN,
JUST TO GET THE SAME THING
THAT SOMEONE NEXT TO YOU
IS GETTING.
AND YOU HAVE
THIS BEAUTIFUL, LUSCIOUS BODY,
AND IT'S JUST KIND OF
JUST STANDING THERE WASTED.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> MONIQUE.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT, MONIQUE.
>> IT'S A REAL MOMENT,
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT,
AND YOU LOOK--
YOU LOOK WONDERFUL.
>> I FEEL THE EXCITEMENT
OF THE ANTICIPATION
THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE
IN A SHOW, AND YOU'RE
FEELING GOOD ABOUT IT INSIDE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> OKAY. MIKAELA.
OKAY, HERE YOU ARE.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE,
"THAT'S THE NEW STAR.
WHO IS SHE AND WHAT'S HER NAME?"
THAT'S WHAT I'D WANT TO KNOW
IF I SAW THIS PICTURE.
LOOK HOW INCREDIBLE IT IS.
FABULOUSLY BIG.
>> YOUR EYEBROWS ARE AMAZING.
YOUR--YOUR JAWLINE IS
INCREDIBLE.
YOU'RE THERE. YOU'RE PRESENT.
>> OKAY. THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> DOMINIQUE.
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT STRIKING.
IT'S NOT REALLY SAYING
ANYTHING PARTICULAR.
YOU'RE KIND OF JUST THERE.
>> I GOTTA SAY THAT, DOMINIQUE--
AT THE FASHION SHOW,
SHE WAS ONE OF THE GIRLS
THAT TOOK A SPILL...
>> OH!
>> BUT YOU DID IT
IN SUCH A JOVIAL MANNER
AND YOU MADE FUN OF YOURSELF
AND YOU SMILED THROUGH IT.
AND LIKE I SAID,
I THINK IT'S AMAZING
WHEN YOUR PERSONALITY
SHOWS THROUGH,
AND HERE, I THINK, YOU KNOW,
YOUR PERSONALITY
COULD SHOW THROUGH MORE.
>> OKAY. THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT IS JACLYN.
>> HI, Y'ALL.
>> ARE YOU EXCITED
TO SEE YOUR PHOTO?
>> UH, YES, MA'AM, I AM.
>> AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> YOUR EYES ARE
SORT OF CINEMATIC, ACTUALLY.
>> THIS PICTURE IS STUNNING,
LUSCIOUS.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
IT'S YOUR FIRST SEASON,
ALTHOUGH YOUR FILM
DID NOT LOOK LIKE THAT AT ALL.
THIS WAS YOUR ONLY GOOD SHOT.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR YOU
TO PULL UP
AND USE THE MUSCLES IN YOUR FACE
SO THAT YOU DON'T GO
DRAGGY DOWN,
'CAUSE YOU ARE CAPABLE
OF EXCELLENCE.
>> OKAY.
>> ALL RIGHT. MOLLY.
>> WOULD YOU GO
TO YOUR FIRST GO-SEE
WITH YOUR MIDRIFF OUT LIKE THAT?
>> I WOULDN'T GO
TO MY LAST GO-SEE
WITH MY MIDRIFF OUT.
>> GO-SEE WITH
YOUR MIDRIFF OUT LIKE THAT!
>> FOR ME, THIS IS
ONE OF THE BEST SHOTS.
>> OOH.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF CHARACTER
THERE.
I LOVE THE MOVEMENT.
>> THE CHIN, THE NECK,
THIS ENERGY--IT'S DYNAMIC.
>> MOLLY, I SAW YOU
IN FRONT OF RUSSELL'S CAMERA,
AND YOU WERE REALLY EVOKING
SOME INTENSE STUFF
OUT OF YOUR EYES.
BUT DON'T LET IT GO
TO YOUR HEAD.
>> (laughs)
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST--
BRITTANI.
>> WHOA.
>> (laughs) TOO MUCH HAIR,
SWOOP, NECKLACE.
SHAKE THAT HAIR OUT.
WHAT'D THE LITTLE SIDE THING?
>> WHAT'S THAT LITTLE--
ON THE SIDE THERE?
>> MY FEATHERS.
>> CHILD, GET RID OF THAT THING.
HONEY,
AND PLEASE RETIRE THAT FOREVER.
>> HEY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT STANDS OUT.
OUT OF ALL THE OTHER PICTURES,
THIS IS JUST UNIQUE.
>> SHE'S DOING A TECHNIQUE
WHERE A MAKEUP ARTIST PULLS
THE TOP OF YOUR EYE UP
AND RIMS THE INSIDE
OF YOUR UPPER LID.
AND YOU LOOK CALM AND GORGEOUS
AND STUNNING.
THIS IS A WORK OF ART.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THE JUDGES ARE
ABOUT TO DELIBERATE RIGHT NOW.
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
IS ELIMINATED.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> SO GIRLS' FIRST PHOTO SHOOT,
SOMEBODY'S GOING HOME
THEIR FIRST WEEK HERE.
>> OKAY. FIRST GIRL.
ALEXANDRIA.
>> ALEXANDRIA.
WHAT A BEAUTIFUL BONE STRUCTURE.
MY GOODNESS,
THE LIGHT JUST LOVES HER.
>> LIKE, THIS JUST SEEMS
SO HIGH FASHION,
IT SEEMS SO EDGY AND COOL
AND RAW AND...
>> I FEEL ALEXANDRIA IS GIVING
WHAT I CALL THE GLAMOUR VIBE.
I MEAN, SHE'S OF THE MOMENT,
AND IT'S FEELING BACKSTAGE.
SHE'S GOT A GREAT PROFILE.
>> DALYA.
>> THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT HER
THAT READS REALLY STRONG
AND ATHLETIC.
>> I LOVE HER FACE.
SHE LOOKS LIKE THE GIRL
THAT JUST IS SO BRAND-NEW
AND HAS SUCH A BIG FUTURE
AHEAD OF HER,
AND SHE HAS NO IDEA
JUST HOW HUGE SHE'S GONNA BE.
>> ABOUT TO, YEAH.
>> NICOLE.
>> NICOLE ISN'T TRULY PRESENT
IN THIS SHOT,
AND THE MOUTH, YOU KNOW,
IS TOO TIGHT.
IT'S LIKE A LITTLE
SORT OF CAT'S BOTTOM.
(cat meows)
>> (laughs) A CAT'S BOTTOM?
NIGEL, HOW DID YOU COME UP
WITH A CAT'S BOTTOM?
>> I'VE SEEN CAT'S BOTTOM MOUTHS
ALL THE TIME.
>> PEOPLE ARE LIKE THIS...
>> (laughs)
>> SO...
>> SARA.
>> I THINK THAT SARA HAS
SOMETHING THAT'S QUIRKY
AND THERE'S SOMETIMES IS
A NEED FOR A QUIRKY MODEL.
>> ONDREI.
>> THE WAY SHE JUST GENTLY
GRABS THAT CHAIR IS
SHE'S HOLDING ON,
YET SHE'S ABOUT TO LET GO.
>> THIS IS A SWEET GIRL
AND A VERY APPROACHABLE
KIND OF...
>> WARM, FRIENDLY, YEAH.
>> GIRL NEXT DOOR.
>> YES.
>> ANGELIA.
BEAUTIFUL EYES.
THEY KIND OF--THEY KINDA GO UP
LIKE JASMINE IN "ALADDIN."
>> BUT WHEN I LOOK AT THE FACE
AND I LOOK AT THE PICTURE--
THAT'S WHAT MODELS ARE
BOOKED FOR,
AND I WOULD NEVER BOOK
A GIRL WHO LOOKED LIKE THIS.
THE FACE, THE REST OF IT
WAS JUST LIKE, UH...
>> HANNAH.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT
WHO'S SURROUNDING HER,
SHE'S--SHE'S THE ONE
WHO'S POPPING THROUGH.
I THINK THIS GIRL CAN TURN
INTO A LITTLE SEX KITTEN.
>> I THINK HANNAH'S VERY PRETTY.
I THINK SHE'S STRIKING
IN THIS PICTURE.
I THINK HER EYES ARE
THE STRONGEST PART.
BUT FOR ME,
I'M NOT READING "MODEL."
>> KASIA.
>> THIS PICTURE
DOESN'T DO IT FOR ME,
BUT I WANT TO SEE HER DO
SOMETHING ELSE, TO GO FORWARD.
>> I LOVE THE CHEEKBONES.
I LOVE
HER EASTERN EUROPEAN LOOKS.
I DON'T KNOW IF I'VE EVER SEEN
A FIERCELY REAL GIRL
WITH EASTERN EUROPEAN LOOKS.
MONIQUE.
>> WHAT--WHAT I LIKE
ABOUT MONIQUE IS
THAT THE EYES ARE TELLING
SO MANY STORIES.
I COULD--LET'S JUST ZOOM IN
ONTO THE EYES.
I LOVE IT.
IT'S AN AD CAMPAIGN
STRAIGHT OFF THE BAT.
>> MIKAELA.
>> I SEE HERE A POTENTIAL,
YOU KNOW,
BIGITALIAN "VOGUE" COVER.
>> I LIKE HER PETITENESS.
I LIKE THE FACT
THAT SHE'S QUITE SMALL,
BUT SHE SEEMS VERY MEEK
AT THE SAME TIME.
LIKE, I WANT TO SEE
HER PERSONALITY.
>> YEAH, IT DOESN'T MATCH
THE FACE, RIGHT?
>> RIGHT.
>> DOMINIQUE.
>> I DIDN'T THINK THIS PICTURE
DOES MUCH FOR HER,
BUT SEEING HER HERE IN PERSON,
THERE IS SOME GREAT BEAUTY
IN HER.
>> I THINK DOMINIQUE NEEDS
AN INJECTION OF FUEL AND ENERGY
INSIDE HER SOUL.
>> YES.
>> AND IF SHE STAYS AROUND
LONG ENOUGH,
I HAVE A MAKEOVER PLAN FOR HER!
>> YES.
>> (imitates Jaclyn) JACLYN--
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> WHILE THIS ISN'T
A GREAT PHOTOGRAPH
FOR THE STORY IDEA,
THERE'S SOMETHING FABULOUS
IN THE LIGHT IN HER EYES.
>> RATHER SWEET.
>> WELL, SHE'S, LIKE, SWEET
AS, LIKE, SWEET TEA CAN BE.
>> YEAH.
>> I MEAN, SHE IS, LIKE,
STRAIGHT-UP, LIKE,
DRINKING SWEET TEA
ON THE FRONT PORCH IN TEXAS.
>> YES. MOLLY. I LOVE
AN INVISIBLE WIND MACHINE.
>> IT'S IN THE EYES, IT'S IN
THE HAIR, IT'S IN THE NECK,
IT'S IN THE BONE STRUCTURE.
THAT'S THE REASON WHY
PEOPLE CALL YOU BACK.
FOR SURE.
>> BRITTANI.
THIS PHOTO IS FRIGHTENING.
>> BEAUTIFUL.
FRIGHTENINGLY BEAUTIFUL.
>> I'M A REALLY BIG FAN OF HER.
I THINK THAT THERE'S SOMETHING
ABOUT HER BONE STRUCTURE
THAT'S--IT'S--IT'S SOFT,
BUT IT HITS THE LIGHT
IN ALL THE RIGHT WAYS,
AND, UH, I THINK
THERE'S SOMETHING REALLY GREAT
ABOUT HER.
>> WE'VE REACHED A DECISION.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> 14 BEAUTIFUL YOUNG LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE 13 PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE GIRLS THAT ARE
STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME I'M GONNA CALL IS
BEST PHOTO,
AND I THINK YOU KNOW BY NOW,
THAT PHOTO WILL BE DISPLAYED
IN YOUR HOME.
>> MOLLY.
>> (whispers) OH, MY GOD.
THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE ABOUT TO CRY.
>> (normal voice) I KNOW.
I'M SO EXCITED.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
RUNNER-UP FOR BEST PHOTO IS
BRITTANI.
ALEXANDRIA.
MIKAELA.
CONGRATULATIONS, MIKAELA.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
DALYA.
HANNAH.
ONDREI.
MONIQUE.
THE NEXT NAME I'M GONNA CALL IS
NICOLE.
>> KASIA.
THE NEXT NAME I'M GOING TO CALL
IS... (imitates Jaclyn) JACLYN.
>> (sighs)
>> (normal voice)
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
THREE GIRLS LEFT,
BUT ONLY TWO PHOTOS IN MY HANDS.
SARA.
>> OH.
>> YOU HAVE
BEAUTIFUL, BEAUTIFUL EYES,
AND WE WANT TO SEE THEM.
THE CAMERA WANTS TO LOVE THEM.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
LADIES, PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
>> TWO BEAUTIFUL LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT IS
STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I'LL ONLY CALL ONE NAME,
AND THE NAME I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN
TO YOUR HOME HERE,
IN DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES,
PACK YOUR BAGS AND GO HOME.
ANGELIA, WE'LL START WITH YOU.
YOU ARE SO BEAUTIFUL,
BUT WHEN THE JUDGES VIEWED
YOUR PICTURE,
WE FELT NO EMOTIONAL CONNECTION,
AND WE WONDER, IS THE GIRL
JUST THE PRETTIEST GIRL
IN THE ROOM,
BUT NOT THE STRONGEST MODEL
IN THE ROOM?
AND THEN WE HAVE YOU, DOMINIQUE.
BEAUTIFUL GIRL,
STRIKING, INTERESTING,
FRECKLES THE JUDGES
HAVE NEVER SEEN,
ABSOLUTELY UNIQUE.
BUT YOUR PHOTO? HMM.
IT'S CAPTURING
WHAT'S GENETICALLY THERE,
BUT NOT WHAT'S INSIDE YOUR SOUL.
SO WHO STAYS
IN THIS COMPETITION?
>> MRS. PERSONALITY--DOMINIQUE.
>> (crying)
(sniffles)
THANK YOU, TYRA.
>> YOUR NAME WAS CALLED
BECAUSE THE JUDGES KNOW
THAT YOU HAVE A FIRE
AND A SPARKLE,
BUT IT MEANS ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
IF YOU CAN'T CAPTURE THIS BEAUTY
ON THIS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> COME HERE.
SO YOU HAVE TO GO HOME
AND PRACTICE...
>> MM.
>> AND GET SOME PICTURES
THAT LOOK MORE STRIKING
THAN YOUARE.
>> OKAY.
I AM SHOCKED THAT I'M GOING HOME
BECAUSE I FELT LIKE I DID BRING
A LOT OF ENERGY
INTO MY PICTURES
AND I KNOW
I'M NOT JUST A PRETTY FACE,
AND I WASN'T ALWAYS
THE PRETTY GIRL AT SCHOOL.
I KNOW MY STUFF,
AND IT'S JUST I DIDN'T GET
A CHANCE TO PROVE IT
AND I DIDN'T GET A CHANCE
TO SHOW THAT I KNOW
HOW TO WORK IT.
BUT I WILL MAKE IT ON MY OWN.
♪♪♪♪♪
Captioned by
Closed Captioning Services, Inc.